as a those into my name is Ray vengo and
I'm a developer advocate for Microsoft I
focus specifically on Internet explorer
and Microsoft edge have you have you
guys heard of those two browsers anybody
yeah how many guys have had pain points
with those two brothers all right I
understand actually i'm going to assume
you've had more pain points with the
previous version internet explorer than
microsoft edge but how many of you
actually tested out Microsoft edge
already okay a couple you well hopefully
I'm gonna help you guys get into
Microsoft edge and feel a little bit
better about Microsoft's browser
strategy that's kind of my focus at
Microsoft I came back to Microsoft
because of that because I was really
excited by what I saw with the new
browser you know Internet Explorer's had
a very long history sometimes it was
really great and sometimes it wasn't so
great but Microsoft's made a very
different effort and concerted effort to
improve the browser experience and
that's where Microsoft edge comes in now
one of the things that I wanted to do
when I came back to Microsoft was make
sure that I truly understood the the
day-to-day work flow of the modern web
developer and it's interesting because
when I rejoined Microsoft back last July
the one thing I told them was all right
well if I'm going to go come back one
thing I need is a macbook so just like
you guys you guys a lot of you use that
well this is my work machine seriously
this is what they gave me to start off
with and the reason I did this is
because it's how can I have a genuine
conversation with any of you guys if I
don't know how you're doing your
day-to-day work how can I know the pain
points that you guys are going through
if I don't know how you're testing our
browser product you guys have you've
expressed over the many years that I've
been doing this that Internet Explorer
has been tough and now we have a brand
new browser but how can I help you guys
be able to effectively test this out if
I'm not using the same equipment that
you guys are and that's why I ended up
with a mac and you know the mac is a
great machine and some of you are on
linux but ultimately i think what
everybody wants is to be at a code cross
browser and that's end but in many cases
what ends up happening is that because
you're on a on a oh s 10 or linux you
end up actually targeting this and part
of the
because you're like well how do i test
out internet explorer how do i test out
Microsoft edge when I don't have a
windows pc and that's part of this
conversation and we have a brand new
browser Microsoft edge which is
fantastic standards-based stuff like
that and I don't want you guys to go
through what this poor guy did this is
actually a web developer who is trying
to test out area explore in a mac all
right I don't let you guys to go through
that type of stuff I want you to feel
good about doing your day-to-day work I
don't want you to struggle now some of
the common questions I get is well why
can't you kill off IE all right I I hear
that all the time and you know I I quit
this is something called old IE PTSD all
right how many of you are feeling that
yeah pretty much the whole entire room I
get it okay well what ends up happening
is you go to this feeling of all man I
had to support these older versions of
Internet Explorer and start making
cartoons like this all right where
Internet Explorer is eating paste on the
side while the other two browsers are
duking it out all right and one of the
things that realized over the years that
this is really because it's a lack of
feature knowledge in the community and
this is not something that I don't blame
the developer community I blame
microsoft I blame myself for not doing a
good enough job of getting the
information out of educating you guys
about the things that we're doing
because I feel pretty good about even
internet explorer 11 how many of you
have actually used internet explorer 11
during your testing or even usage well
you've if you've done that then you
probably know that we have a pretty good
level of support of standards-based
features and this is it's amazing what I
encounter developers that don't know
this or that we have some really really
good toolings using the f12 developer
tools where you can do everything from
obviously script debugging to profiling
to all types of emulations across
different form factors it's really
important now one of the bigger reasons
that I'm an advocate of not killing off
internet explorer's because the w3c and
having multiple reference
implementations of browsers you want
multiple browser vendors out there
vetting these features to ensure that
the features are ready for production
you don't want to go back to the old
days remember how all these features
were coming out and they were just part
of
I six and they became standards because
one vendor was dominant we don't want to
go back to those days we want to have
multiple vendors that are venting all
these features so we have multiple touch
points and multiple thought processes
going on about why these features
matters and how they should be
implemented we want a thoughtful
approach having multiple vendors going
out there and thinking about that makes
a lot of sense and improves the process
and knowledge is power I want to share
that knowledge with you guys I want to
make sure that you guys have the
information you need to be successful so
I'm going to ask all of you right now
real quick just to write down some links
that are going to be really important to
you guys okay first one is called Deb
modern-day eat some of you murder may
already know about modern-day e this is
the tooling site that we produced a
while back that gives a bunch of
information a bunch of tools that makes
your development cycle a little bit
easier so please just jot down dev
modern IE put it into your browser if
you have something open and the reason
is because we are trying to be a lot
more transparent about information we
have our road map out in there this is
called the status dashboard it's really
important so if you want to see what
type of features we're looking at
producing let me spark this up I'll go
here this is by the way this is
Microsoft edge all right some of you
admit this may be the first look you can
see it's a very different chrome that
you what you've traditionally been used
to an Internet Explorer it's very
streamlined but i'm not going to focus
on that right now what I am focused on
is Deb modern-day eat and this is where
you want to go to it's going to be this
when you want to get the most relevant
information about Microsoft edge and
internet explorer eventually but the key
one is this right here the plot and step
of platform status because this is where
our road maps at if you want to know
what type of status we're at in a
specific feature this is where you go so
for example if we want to talk about I
don't know the battery status API what's
under consideration but if you wanted to
know whether we're going to include
canvas was already an edge this is where
you can understand what we're thinking
about and the great thing is that you
have an opportunity now to vote these
features up we if you go to user voice
modern day e you have a choice now you
can look for the features that are
important to you and you can vote those
up and the features that get the highest
votes get the attention I think that's a
pretty fair approach to it all right so
I want
make sure that you have that link let me
go back to my slides real quick now I'm
going to ask you to just kind of write
these down these are bit ly links now
the IE developer guides every time we
release a version of internet explorer
we've also put in developer guys that
outline the new features that are in
internet explorer and we're going to
continue to do that with Microsoft edge
but it's interesting because it a lot of
developers didn't know about this and
this is really important when you're
trying to think about future features so
bit ly / IE deb guides the I
compatibility cookbook which is
incredibly important because we outline
things that we know are going to be
compatibility issues and we try to make
your lives easier by giving giving you a
heads up of what's happening that way
you can plan your development
accordingly so in this case IE compat
cookbook and then lastly we do have
really good to developer tools this is
not the you know ie8 debug toolbar
thingy majiggy that you had to install
the plugin now these are real developer
tools guys so check it out go to bit ly
f12 dev tools and check it out now why
should I test IE that's another common
question I get you know ultimate is
going to be up to you and your user base
but I wanted to point out a couple
graphs and this is one that always
strikes home fifty-five percent of the
Internet is using Internet Explorer in
some fashion this is based on net market
share now some of you may say well
that's net marking sure what about
statcounter well even with statcounter
22% is still a pretty high figure that's
twenty-two percent desktop market share
worldwide again ultimately you have to
use your own analytics to determine what
you want to test for but these are still
compelling stats all right now the other
question I get is why can't I push
corporations to upgrade how many of you
use any of these services these
companies for services okay look pretty
large number of you okay some of you may
be overseas you may not use this
ultimately these companies have a
responsibility to you guys using chase
of using fidelity all these guys want to
make sure that they manage your
investments they want to manage your
money they want to manage your services
the right way so they have to go through
specific internal auditing services that
are critical to making sure that the
information they're processing is
accurate some of that is government
mandated and some of those are auditing
and certification
on specific software versions how many
of you knew that okay only a maybe a
couple okay this is something that's
really important so when you ask that
question why can't we push companies to
upgrade because some of them actually
have to certify their software to
specific software versions so they
certify to Internet Explorer 8 at a cost
of 10 million dollars they're not going
to want to do that every six weeks or
every 12 weeks the large large
investment that they have to make they
have to make sure that they their
software worked accurately so I think if
you make a trade on fidelity you want to
make sure that trade is accurate or when
you make a deposit into chase you want
to make sure your money is in that bank
account right well chase wants to make
sure they can do that same thing and
they depend on software that we produce
as well for that so that's why we can't
push them but what we are trying to do
is give them tools that allow them to
migrate to modern technologies in a
little bit more methodical fashion so
for example Enterprise mode Internet
Explorer comes in internet explorer 11
it's a high fidelity emulation of
Internet Explorer 8 that allows
enterprises to be to run their legacy
stuff while still focusing on modern
technologies this gives them that
migration path they can test out their
old legacy stuff using Internet Explorer
and if it works great that means it's
only one browser running both scenarios
so we're providing that and the other
thing we provide is enterprise site
discovery tool kit which is a tool that
lets them analyze all their applications
and figure out which are the sites that
they use the most in which of the sites
that they'd have to migrate to modern
technologies based on what they're
implementing they might use active xba
chose or whatever and that way they have
some kind of visibility into what it
takes to get them to move forward now
one of the great things i see here and i
want to kind of highlight this graph is
that i'm seeing an upward trend on
internet explorer 11 and that's great
because all the other browser shares are
going down and we want that we actually
want all the older versions of a near
explorer to go down while the more
modern versions go up that means that
it's one less two less browsers that you
have to focus on and i'm sitting that a
net mark share and i'm also seeing on
statcounter so whether you're using
doesn't matter which analytic you're
using we're still seeing an upward trend
on internet explorer 11 that's really
important because that means that you
guys are gonna get the most
modern version soon enough and one of
the things that we're doing to help that
is we're giving a Windows 10 away to
anybody with windows 7 8 or 8.1 that's a
free upgrade that's that's a pretty
impressive thing you're talking millions
of users are going to be prompted to get
a free version of Windows this is
unprecedented we've never done that all
right what that means is I expect to see
a very high usage of Microsoft edge
which is what you guys want edge is our
new browser that's going to be standards
compliant there's going to be on a much
faster release cycle and hopefully that
will end up sun setting internet
explorer very soon my fingers breadth
okay now enough of that soapbox talk
what I do want to do is actually dive
into this because I know that we only
have a short amount of time I want to
make sure I highlight how do you test
Internet Explorer and edge again the
microsoft edge deb portal is your home
there ok and i'm going to dive into that
real quick and the reason it's your home
is because basically here is where we
have a couple of options we have
something called remote IE which lets
you virtualize internet explorer within
the context of your mac i'm going to
show you how that looks we have virtual
machines for every version of internet
explorer across multiple OS versions we
can also generate screenshots and we can
also generate a quick side scan that
shows different compatibility issues so
if i bring up remote IE which is
actually a really cool feature you can
go ahead and i'll double-click on ray
bangles internet explorer what it does
is it actually goes ahead and hoping the
internet works connects out to our
remote as our services hopefully login
let's see bear with me one second
connects to our remote Azeris services
this works and what will get is a
virtualized version of internet explorer
sitting on my desktop I didn't work that
time let me try this one here with me
there we go come on
this one work okay great all right so
here if you look it looks basically like
I have a true native app and what the
cool thing about this is this is
internet explorer 11 it gives me the
tooling that I want so here's the f12
developer tools and of course i can
bring up any site i won in this case is
bringing up modern IE maybe i want to go
to blog that Ray bango calm it'll go out
there and bring up my blog now this is
very useful obviously if you're in a
staging or in a production environment
not very useful if you're trying to test
out a site on your local pc so one of
the things that I've actually been
noodling on quite a bit is how do you
actually do that well the great thing is
i stumbled upon a tool called n grok
which is freaking awesome so here's a
little site i have it's called rep chord
i'm going to launch this HTTP server
they're launched a little web server
here and when i go here to localhost
bear with me one second i go back to my
browser's you can see it localhost 8080
so this is a little CrossFit site that a
buddy of mine let me borrow so i can
count demo for you guys and this is
great on my local machine but i actually
want to see it on remote IE so i'm going
to go back here and let me bring up
another tab and I'll go to end rock and
n grok should be in Greco it's say HTTP
i believe is HTTP 8080 and what it's
going to do is going to create a secure
tunnel for me that i can then use to
actually bring up the site within any
type of remote scenario so in this case
notice that it's bringing up this whole
URL here now i take this i'll go back to
remote i eat and poop and i'll paste
this right in here and bring it up now
what I'm doing is I'm leveraging remote
ie which normally would not allow me to
hit my local server and now I can
actually test it out this is actually
rep cord running on my local box but now
I can use it within remote I eat that's
a big deal that's actually pretty hot
this was something that we couldn't do
before but i like i said i want the
noodle i was really frustrating that we
had this great service but you couldn't
ping your local you know your local
resources why would we put that out
there so now with n groc you can
actually do that and the cool thing is
you can use this also for any virtual
machines that you
decide to install on your Mac as well so
we terminate that so you guys you guys
don't hack my machine all right and now
so going back to go back here bear with
no second alright so angaraag is awesome
is to go to anger are calm you can
install it if you have homebrew you can
actually install it via homebrew as well
now the other thing is and we again
remote IE the cool thing about is you go
here you sign in you do have to have a
Microsoft Live ID but you select your
region if you select your region you
have different ones make sure you select
the one that's closest to you so that
way you get the best performance but the
good thing is again you don't have to
install anything its except for the
microsoft remote desktop app once it
comes up it creates a virtualized
version of that kind of cool stuff now
the one thing that you guys definitely
have used quite a bit and we've actually
seen a lot of stats on this is the
virtual machines how many of you guys
have taken advantage of virtual machines
off of modern done a lot of you and
they're awesome so you know we do have
for Windows Mac and Linux so whichever
operating system is is yours go for it
and the great thing is again we have all
different types of versions this is the
key part of it we wanted to make sure
that you guys can test across any type
of internet explorer version and
operating system version as well because
of course there's nuances depending on
which one you're at so make sure you
select the one you want so let's say
it's a tie 11 on Windows 10 and you can
select your platform parallels
VirtualBox or VMware totally up to you
guys the one thing we don't have right
now is Microsoft edge on there because
it's still not out in production we're
still working on that but there's a
different way of grabbing that so i'll
make sure i show that before we kind of
run out now we also have a screenshot
service i went ahead and ran this ahead
of time so you can see it would it look
like because it does take a little while
to generate the screenshots but here's
the miami herald of course my hometown
paper all right but notice it does give
you screenshots across different types
of browsers different types of OSS and
browsers so it's a nice little service
that against it's free for you use and
also we have a site scanning report so
you put in a URL and it gives you
feedback on what we know are certain
compatibility issues that might cause
you guys problems so in this case for
example notice that they're using
underscore one point oh well we've known
we know just based on information
telemetry we've collected that
underscore one point 0 will
some compat is you go up in different
versions of Internet Explorer so what we
recommend is to go to the next most
compatible version which is 1.7 we also
look for other things like been there
prefixes which we all know if you don't
prefix correctly if you don't go ahead
and do it across from all the browser
versions and browser vendors you're
going to have some quirks some rendering
quirks so we try to give you as much
compatibility information as possible so
you guys can make informed decisions
about your development process all right
now the other service that I recommend
is a service called browser stack how
many of you have used that a couple you
this is a paid service but you know what
its incredible is it's actually
phenomenal the great thing about it is
it's not windows specific it's not
internet explorer specific works across
any type of OS and it's within your
browser itself so if i wanted to test
out windows 10 using internet explorer
11 i can go here it actually sparks up a
session and the cool thing is if i go
ahead and start up a local server and
i'll start it up again i can actually go
here back to my browser and i want to
bring up localhost and now within within
google chrome i am testing out internet
explorer 11 running the local site
that's on my peace my macbook all right
that's a little inception type of stuff
there all right so this is pretty cool
and the great thing is this is just
through a browser extension that you
install and basically does the local
tunneling for you again it's a little
bit of a you know it's a little pricing
service that you have to pay for but you
know what sometimes you got to pay for
the good stuff and I'm a firm believer
that you pay for software that solves
you solves problems for you guys so I
think browser sack is a great piece of
software and it's definitely worth the
investment all right
we also have webdriver support in the
internet explorer 11 I'm not an expert
in webdriver but if you guys need
information on that let me know and I
can get your information and put you in
contact with the team now how do you
test out Microsoft edge well the easiest
way is to download the ISO from insider
windows com so take a moment and write
that down insider that windows com all
right this version that the version of
Windows 10 that you saw me running is
the same version that you guys would
download it already includes Microsoft
edge on it so you get all the features
and you can start seeing how Microsoft
edge works on your site you can check
out the rendering the great thing about
Microsoft edge is that we are shooting
for ninety-nine percent compatibility it
compatibility interoperability with
other browsers so your sites should work
okay we want to make sure that they work
and also I have a limited number of USB
sticks that actually have Windows 10 on
it where you can just pop it into your
macbook that's macbook only you pop it
into your macbook you restart your
macbook and it actually brings it up for
you so before the end of the session or
before you guys run out come over and
see me and I'll hand them out I only
have a limited number though okay so I
just want to keep it everybody aware
that now what about mobile mobile is
another challenge obviously for testing
across any type of mobile browser one of
the things that we're doing is we're
coming up with a project called borlänge
s and Vorlon was a project that actually
it's a JavaScript library that allows
for remote communication with specific
individual devices if you've used winery
before for example which I'm going to
talk about here as well it's very
similar winery in that sense the
interesting thing about this is of
course it's Microsoft so you'd be
surprised that we actually releases as
open source and we are accepting
contributions in tint all right but the
cool thing is that it's also has a plug
in a plug-in scenario where you guys can
contribute plugins to the actual
framework itself to extend it out and is
powered by node and socket i/o so
definitely join us in kind of extending
that out I'm going to demo it so you can
see it the other one is winery these are
the two libraries that I've used the
most how many of you use winery in the
pin past ok klipsch a couple you and
winery is another very very awesome
remote testing library which it solves
that remote that remote device
type of scenario let me show you real
quick so what I'll do is I'm going to
actually close these down here and I'm
going to bring up the spark of or lon
first so i got my locals here so i'm
going to go here and then Vorlon is just
a matter of typing in Borland it's an
MPN module so i just installed it boom
it comes up and it's listening on port
1337 it's basically a little web server
that just listens on port 1337 and one
of the things that you need to do is in
your code you need to add this
javascript script tag in here ok this is
what actually allows for lon to read
your dom understand what's going on
within your page analyze it and
represent it so now when i go here and
I'll go back to my browser and i go
local hosts 1337 vorlons going to bring
me up a dashboard ok the dashboard
doesn't show anything right now but as
soon as I go into my my app localhost
8080 and let me actually break this part
here boom and bring us here you'll see
that basically I have now a new app here
and it's expects if I click on that it
expands out it shows me my whole DOM and
the good thing is that I can actually
click through here and actually inspect
the individual elements and get feedback
on what's happening so I can't go to the
level of doing like script debugging yet
this is something that we're actually
working on as a plug-in but you can go
ahead and have a cab access to the
console so if i go here i guess say
something like inner HTML equals foo and
i do that and changes immediately there
so you have immediate response and
feedback to understand what the what
changes would happen and you can change
attributes on your CSS as well property
values so if I said margin bottom is I
don't know 50 pixels then it affects it
as well in real time so from a mobile
device perspective this makes a lot of
sense again this is an evolving library
so I definitely ask you guys to jump in
get involved and contribute the plugins
now the other one that I want to show
you is winery so I'll go here and let me
terminate a for lawn and I'll go winery
HTTP port and 80 81 all right so I'll
bring up winery now winery is very
similar to this and it's based on webkit
so a lot of the stuff is going to be
very familiar to you guys if you use the
chrome developer tools notice that
nothing shows up now winery has a really
cool little bookmarklet so if I click on
this bookmarklet here notice that all
the Dom shows up now there's a little
bit more of a feature filled type of
scenario so you have access to resources
network timings timelines console the
whole thing it's actually a really slick
thing it's again it's a little bit more
mature but you know we're working on
board on we're trying to make it much
better so I expand this out I can go
here and change different things let's
say I want to go down here and I'll
expand this div out and we're says the
rep cord I can change this out to the
record and up its down here someplace
but basically shows real time updating
of the page as well again a little bit
more mature app it's been around for a
long time but this is where you're going
to what you're going to use primarily
for your mobile testing all right this
is what's going to allow you to inspect
the Dom elements check all the
attributes change them in real time and
work with them so Vorlon and winery are
your two choices there's also and I'm
sorry if I'm speaking fast as you so I
know I'm limited on time and I want to
get through this there's also a couple
of other ones Adobe Edge inspect which
is a great tool I haven't used this I
know Brian lose here so Brian maybe you
can help them out later on or not and
ghost lab which is another one that I've
just that I've just recently found it's
a paid service but it also looks pretty
impressive as well the one thing that we
have been pushing for extensively within
the developer relations team is a
headless version of ie how many you guys
want to have this version of ie
everybody and the reason is we want to
include that into your development
workflow your continuous integration
workflow we've been pushing on it it is
in process we are working on that okay
it is something that's really critically
important when we know that once we do
that is going to make your lives easier
all right so basically we are
continuously improving we are working on
giving you the tools that you need and
lower
friction to testing Internet Explorer
Microsoft edge but ultimately we need
your feedback we need you guys to be
continuously involved we need you guys
to be testing we need to read that
feedback to know what are the one of the
friction points you're encountering what
are the problems that you're seeing in
the browser and we need you guys testing
Internet Explorer and Microsoft edge
there's still a lot of customers out
there using the older version of browser
but we also want your feedback on new
stuff because that's the stuff that's
going to be the new shiny toys for you
guys all right also remember that we do
have good tools that tooling stuff that
the tools team wants your feedback as
well so there's new features that you
want in there please let us know that's
what I'm here my twitter handle is ray
bango re y ba ng oh and I'm always
listening for feedback from you guys and
please reach out to me here while I'm
here now there's some other resources
that I want to make sure I list make
sure of course you got dev modern day e
and sorry and the new blog for the
microsoft edge team is going to be right
there blog windows com mms edge dev also
follow that twitter account ms edge dev
and also ms edge dev tools for our
tooling team and finally thank you very
much for your time guys come on doesn't
want to go there we go thank you
you